dominique verdeilhan vous êtes en direct
avec nous depuis le palais de justice
donc ce n'est pas une surprise cette
révision elle n'est pas encore décidée
on va attendre une demi-heure mais c'est
vrai que si on ne fait pas beaucoup de
pronostics en matière de justice ça
serait une énorme surprise si les
magistrats ne décidez pas en début
d'après-midi de la révision du procès de
patrick dils puisque doute il y a ça
serait également un événement judiciaire
parce que depuis 1989 date de la
nouvelle procédure des révisions pénal
il n'y a eu qu'un seul précédent avec
reed allouche alors j'allais dire la
seule incertitude c'est l'éventuelle
remise en liberté dès ce soir de patrick
dils ça serait logique eu égard aux
textes de la présomption d'innocence en
vigueur depuis janvier 2001 mais
l'avocat général au cours de ses
réquisitions s'était opposé à cette
remise en liberté d'abord au nom de
l'ordre public et eu égard aux familles
des victimes ensuite pour protéger
patrick dils jusqu'à son nouveau procès
alors un nouveau procès si l'ia qui
aurait lieu devant la cour d'assises dès
mineurs vous exercez surprenant puisque
patrick 10 est âgé aujourd'hui de 30 ans
sauf que ces larges au moment des faits
qui entrent en ligne de compte et à
l'époque patrice avait 16 ans